a three is just around the kana so now
seems like a pretty good time to talk
about all the things that are to look
forward to this year we've all the games
both expected and unexpected to the big
publisher announcements and all the
surprises in between here are my most
anticipated things first up we should be
finding out what's going on with our new
consoles this year specifically the new
versions of the ps4 and the Xbox one the
BS Borneo and Xbox one Scorpio are
rumored to be upgraded versions of the
existing current gen consoles burkas
said to be more powerful faster and
include the capacity to run virtual
reality games that said the Xbox one
scope here will supposedly run almost
true teraflops faster than the near
before the scorpio arrives it's been
reported that a mini Xbox one said to be
40% smaller than the current model will
arrive later this year unfortunately all
this is only speculation at this stage
but smart money says Microsoft and Sony
will have quite a bit to officially
announce in each of their press
conferences Nintendo doesn't have a lot
on their plate this year in fact if not
from the possibility that we may hear
them talk about the index console it's
pretty much just the legends of Zelda
for Wii U and well it's pretty much just
that but you know what I'm ok with that
Nintendo have already said they're
dedicating their show floor presence to
The Legend of Zelda so will surely get a
much deeper look at the gameplay and
narrative of the new game in April
Nintendo announced that the game's
release would be delayed into 2017 and
that it will be coming to both the Wii U
and the Enix producer Eiji Aonuma said
the team is rethinking the conventions
of Zelda but what exactly does that mean
well hopefully we'll find out next week
of course this year expecting to hear a
lot more about the games that have
already been announced
choking recoil horizon zero dawn and the
Last Guardian but what about the best
part of a3 the surprise announcement
here's what we've got our fingers
crossed cool that's two games in
particular I want to call out to you to
you know decide which is the more
unrealistic personally I've been waiting
for years to see beyond been able to
resurface and with Ubisoft a little more
free up this year given there's no major
Assassin's Creed game coming this could
be good timing for an official
announcement oh maybe we'll just get
more Assassin's Creed Ruby Troy looks
back in 2011 you'd be stops Michelle and
sells said Beyond Good and Evil 2 was
well into development and this year on
sale reaffirmed he is still working on
it that's that he has been thinking a
lot of this time into the upcoming open
world survival game wild lately so if
not this year maybe next or the one
after the second rumored game i've got
for you is Red Dead Redemption - yeah I
know it sounds like a half-life 3 level
myth but this really could be happening
although Tech's who already confirmed
rockstar wouldn't be releasing a new
game until at least April of next year
that doesn't mean they are working on
something now CEO Strauss well dictates
that the company would be at e3 in a big
way this year which sounds like a much
bigger deal than more GTA online updates
if you ask me next up it seems they're
very few shooter fans who aren't holding
out for more news about battlefield one
ea may have not been instantly sold on
the idea of setting the next battlefield
game in world war one but it sure as
hell seems like everybody else's the
game's launch trailer quickly became the
most liked trailer of all time on
YouTube dice of said players will be
able to make use of World War one
weapons both ranged and melee various
armed vehicles biplanes as well as
battleships and horses that should be
able to ride as yes all we've seen from
the game is the reveal trailer from last
month so there's bound to be plenty
still to be announced this in three last
but not least I'd love for e3 this year
to deliver our first proper look at Mass
Effect Andromeda
so far we have a couple of vague
cinematic trailers and a truck full of
rumors and fan speculation to work off
but not nearly enough to get a solid
picture and what we can actually expect
from Andromeda we did get lucky back in
April when leaked albeit dated gameplay
footage surfaced which showed us a
jetpack among other things we've been
told that the maker will be making a
valiant hopefully less bumbly return
Shepard won't be in the new game it's
set in a new galaxy and it will include
a multiplayer component again even
though the game has been pushed back to
2017 it's highly likely that we'll be
getting a bunch of new details on
Andromeda coming through those are a few
of the things I'm really excited to see
at e3 this year but do let me know what
you've got your eye on and what you're
keen to be more of I'll be back after e3
but dude stay tuned to games but for all
the latest announcements and news from
the show and I'll catch against me
you